When you hear the word improvisation,
what do you think of?
You May 1st think of Improv comedy.
You see,
what I did is acting.
You may have also thought of improvised
jazz breaks,
freestyle rap,
or even improvised explosive.
The reason
each of these things still counts as
Improv is because Improv isn't defined
by the product,
but rather the process for making the
product improvising is creating and
performing spontaneously and without any
preparation.
So in film,
any dialogue,
camera shot,
or even a reaction that's unrehearsed or
unprepared can be improv.
Anthony Hopkins got an unrehearsed
reaction out of Jodie foster when he
went off script to make fun of her
accent Gfr,
the Dag a coal mine,
I mean just tingling and Alan Rickman
surprised expression in die hard comes
from the stuntmen dropping him on the
count of two,
not three.
There is no doubt that improv leads to
hilarious performances.
You don't know you're gay.
How I saw you make a spinach dip and a
Lopa sourdough bread once and actors
intuition can make for the best laughs,
tears or surprises,
no matter how subtle,
like the improvised clapping of the
joker.
Yeah.
In this essay,
I want to talk about the strengths and
limitations of Improv and why filmmakers
use different cinematic techniques to
make their films appear improvised.
The best improvisation is when actors
play the game of the scene.
In any improvised scene.
Each actor has certain rules for how to
act and react based on their character's
personality,
and what roles do is they free us up to
improvise,
right?
By giving ourselves these constrictions
that guide our impulses,
it funnels our creative process into
some kind of product.
The process of improvisation and those
rules help us create something.
The rules the actor must follow along
with the conflict between characters
makes an improvised scene work well.
Good at Improv stems from conflict and
personality with each character playing
the game.
Hey,
when you hear the most annoying sound in
the world,
Dustin Hoffman's reaction was
improvised.
When an actual taxi driver drove onset
during the filming of midnight cowboy
boy
reaction completely embodies his
character.
The conflict is realistic and it adds to
his character showing he's not as smooth
and cool as tries to appear.
The same applies to dramatic Improv.
Robert De Niro perfectly embodies travis
is loneliness,
isolation,
paranoia,
and aggression.
With this improvised scene,
you talking to me,
talking to me,
play the game,
follow the rules.
Improvisation doesn't work when
characters don't play the game in
pixels.
Adam Sandler has a meeting with the
president and other executives and out
of nowhere he just starts going around
the room insulting people.
The conflict makes no sense and the
insulting doesn't go along with
Sandler's personality.
I'm convinced Adam Sandler partially
improvise the scene and it's painful to
watch because it doesn't come close to
playing the game.
GRANDPA,
I'll see you around maybe a nursing
home.
One limitation of improvisation is
oftentimes the lack of a resolution to
the scene referred to as the button.
The button is the final moment before
the end of the scene that resolves the
conflict with a final joke or comment
key,
and peele very consistently has the
button at the end of their sketches that
neatly ends the game.
For example,
they have a sketch where college
football players state their names and
the game is that their names get more
and more ridiculous.
Call royal smoochy walls versus Meyer.
The button is a resolution to the chaos
of the names and ends the sketch
perfectly.
Dan Smith,
Byu.
Some improvise scenes don't have the
button.
The result is seems that either go too
long or have an unsatisfying ending.
Director.
Judd apatow has great improvised scenes
with great jokes,
but the drawback is the scenes don't
really end.
They sometimes kind of just stopped.
The nature of spontaneity means an
improvised scene can't always be
structured as well as a scripted scene.
This isn't always the case for
improvisation though sometimes the
ending is perfect,
but it's not a certainty with a scene
that's entirely improvised.
Why don't you just make 10 louder and
make tend to be the top number and make
that a little loud?
These cards are 11
Martin Scorsese likes to mimic
improvisation in his films.
Despite them actually being scripted.
He makes the scenes look like a
documentary as if they're unrehearsed to
the point where he blurs the line
between documentary and fiction.
The effect is films that seem extremely
realistic and spontaneous means streets
appears very improvised.
The opening title sequence in a home
video aspect ratio has characters act
very naturally.
The camera shots are all handheld.
The music is to sal chick and even the
text was super imposed using blown up
typewriter text.
A method commonly reserved for
documentaries and home videos.
The opening sequence shows everyday life
for this group of Italian Americans in
New York.
The use of footage and action that looks
improvised makes the movie seem more
casual and realistic.
Contrast this movie with something like
the Godfather with an epic score,
dramatic deaths,
intense acting and cryptic dark lighting
and you see how mimicked improvisation
gives a totally different mood to a
movie.
The fictional documentary style goes as
far back as citizen Kane when the news
on the march sequence recreated real
life new segments making Charles Kane
seemed like a real world figure while
also establishing the contrast between
his public and private life.
My wife used to farm and she was
nervous.
She had also,
it's a wonderful,
amazing cuisines.
She used to fall asleep.
Improv does more than just make us
laugh.
Improvisation is a process that makes
for great scenes.
Sometimes an actor's best tool is
getting into character and seeing what
can happen spontaneously and even when
it's imitated.
The improvised documentary look,
adds realism to a film.
So don't forget,
an actor can give a great performance
based solely on the process they go
through.
Internally.
Masa Graham,
much.
I gray,
I'm Martha Graham or Twyla Twyla Twyla
are Michael [inaudible].
Michael Kid might go,
kid Michael,
kid on Madonna,
Madonna,
but you keep it all inside.
Thanks for watching.